greetings from podcast Ville its
Thursday the 12th of [ __ ]
December somebody's birthday I don't
know whose it is
it don't matter the church is brought to
you by Stan's socks let me tell you
something and I'm gonna tell you one
time they're the most comfortable socks
that I own when I'm on the road they
give me pep in my step if I know I'm
gonna go to Chicago Airport or Dallas or
one of those airports where you got to
walk for 20 [ __ ] minutes I put my
stance on sir
Stan's socks aren't that comfortable and
they support the people in your life the
way they support you all right get them
at Stan's socks they're not just comfy
they're gonna turn heads do me a favor
right now the church family gets a great
offer from Stan's you ready go to Stan's
calm slash Church and you'll get a free
pair of socks with any purchase Stan's
is the best way to get everybody off
your holiday shopping list that Stan's
grab a pen capital S ta and see e.com
slash church and get your free pair of
socks because if you're not Stan's that
just sucks you know I'm saying the
church is also brought to you by one of
the best gives you the gift right now
listen I'm throwing little things at you
that these gifts are tremendous they're
affordable and that people don't see em
coming like the tushie you like Joey
what's a trishy it's a portable bidet
you install in ten minutes by yourself
so she sprays water directly into that
rotten [ __ ] [ __ ] of yours and
removes a poop completely so you're not
sitting on [ __ ] [ __ ] all day
and bacteria that leads to nasty things
like hemorrhoids yeast infection UTI and
the most common itchy [ __ ] and skid
marks do me a favor go - hello - she's
calm today right now they started $79
and tushies latest product Leticia
element helps you get everything out but
we'll start right here go - hello -
she's calm take a look at the selection
of the days they have it's gonna blow
your [ __ ] mind you see something you
like press in church and get 10% off
your order
this is the [ __ ] Christmas gift
next time you look at Grandma think to
yourself what does that [ __ ] bat
smell like and get it a [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright
hello Toshi calm / Church Lee kick this
[ __ ] mule dance soda what's the
story did I think with the right music
and you beside me in a car you could
talk me into robbing a bank
oh please this is definitely Ida if we
had the right playlist I lower my ear I
love all this [ __ ] you know I do you
want to go get that I'd like we're just
us first federal is about to catch the
done and I got a boy that's what I used
to do before I did anything evil yeah
I'd get McCullen and last some [ __ ]
music just buy it up yeah
Sabbath bloody Sabbath I want revenge I
want blood I'd walk around and I'd crawl
in through a window take your coke and
leave Spotify should give playlists to
incarcerated people just in what they
hyped up on imagine seeing those things
enjoy this got me to murder a family of
four [ __ ] crazy
when Charles Manson killed ISA yeah man
so you do a Spotify playlist what's
happening brother dude thanks for having
me man it's nice to finally I'm a fan so
it's nice to know I'm a fan of yours
it's funny you have a great resume you
did stand-ups on Netflix yeah you've
been with Tommy central but it's so
weird when you got into comedy any time
before 2000 your goal was ultimately HBO
and then it just went away yeah they
started putting on George Klein and all
these old comics that yeah they're
interesting but they really wanted
relevant and nobody wanted to see him
yeah and I appreciate when HBO was doing
but it wasn't getting nowhere Netflix
came along and stole the show yeah HBO
sat there with their dick in their hand
I don't know what the [ __ ] to do you
know we all grew up on HBO
yeah I've seen HBO was the epitome I did
not want to be on Showtime
okay that was in the beginning HBO is
the first draft HBO was the first drawn
wrath and then somewhere along the line
like at anything in life you know
something new popped up hot which we all
appreciate Netflix is doing a great jobs
good for all around for Connell mean
because of Netflix but now HBO saying
you know what I think we're gonna regain
what was once ours now yeah it's free
game now I think we're gonna do
something different with specials bah
bah bah bah bah bah so I congratulate
you on that you got to the top floor of
the specials I mean you did Comedy
Central definitely yeah hitting the and
I'm not putting Netflix down at all
comedy saying no I'm just saying that
you know Central started in 91 and
Comedy Central started you know one of
the first show of this is they had that
was big was politically incorrect yeah
which later moved on to ABC which is now
Real Time with Bill Maher for a lot of
people don't know that yet growing up
Comedy Central I think like I'm one of
the first generation of kids that grew
up with first cable but then you had
Comedy Central 91 I was 8 years old and
I was able to watch a bunch of comedy
that you know I would have never had
access to before Comedy Central but HBO
was still the thing where we got the
free weekend you would try to tape
whatever specials you could and watch it
and I member being a kid and seeing like
those half hours like Chappelle's
half-hour Patton Oswalt's half hour from
the mid-90s and you'd see all those in
Batman this is the [ __ ] HBO is because
you knew they were unedited Comedy
Central was still cable so then even
Chappelle's killing them softly and all
those kind of specialists or you know
both rocks getting one was like oh [ __ ]
it was great but there was like also
like this pressure it was bigger than
black our HBO yeah both cuz I'm bigger
and blacker and bring the pain because I
never had HP own HBO for me was like a
hotel on vacation was like a big thing
oh snap we got HBO like they're swearing
in these specials yeah like it was a bit
was a big deal find out what year HBO
started it had to be if I had to take a
guess I say 73 74 yeah I still my
friends talking about a movie called
groove tube yeah okay
and it was the either lead up to a
we'll call Kentucky Fried Chicken
Kentucky Fried film or vice versa 72 72
it was the whole cast the sad might live
before Sam my life yeah we chase John
Candy see who the cast was I love the
SNL on 72 no that's good turkey fried
out of group two groups if you look so
this is basically like you're like
seeing like a mixtape of comedy no this
does not stand up yeah but I'm saying
like of improv people that are gonna go
on to be SNL right this is this was yeah
brilliantly done who was the cast ken
Shapiro Richard Belzer we just hugged
about Chevy Chase buzzy Linhart who I've
never heard of Crispin Bear Berkeley
Harris all these names were going oh no
but there were like improv people that
was well known and you know was just
sketches like Kentucky Fried movie was a
sketch there in a courtroom and [ __ ]
all of a sudden the attorney takes open
the briefcase up and takes a dick out to
put something it's the same we have
another planet and all this [ __ ] man
you're 12 and you stab what you want to
see 18 kids yeah it's hysterical yeah
another scene of three black guys
playing dice and the white guy walks up
puts a construction helmet on and he
looks to all three guys and they those
[ __ ] me runs adjacent yeah and then
it shows you know but the moral of the
story is Kentucky Fried movie 72 you
said well HBO started in 74 74 so humble
numbers 11 that was correct and that's
what else started in 75 I was dying to
see it
oh yeah okay so yeah the word on the
street was and the scene where a guy
chased a naked woman but it was on HBO
again nobody had HBO no one had his
brand new so there's dur member sitting
my mom
Kuban mom yeah like breaking it down for
her how I needed HBO in school you know
cuz they don't know they're watching
Telemundo you hush the subscription to a
pay channel for a teddy oh yeah
really let me talk to you what that's
big thinking it had to be like 14.95
yeah we'll do it on one condition we
split it I was like fine there was a box
you rather get boxes knows yeah it was a
box with a switch and it was like 1 2 14
14 to 28 28 yeah and those are the
channels yeah and then they were porno
channels Lee I don't like 56 but they
will come and slant it yeah
scramble in come and scramble data you
had to scramble the button and you'd
catch like the [ __ ] and you'd start
jerking off then it would blow away
I still remember putting my mother
together that's all for HBO her going
out the groove to being on and me
sitting Mac underwear off ready to bang
this [ __ ] out to the [ __ ]
groove what a Space Shuttle it was just
a scene yeah
did you and there was no way like now
there's DVR now you can rewind me but
then you had to almost that's it it was
it was timing there's all time I mean
yeah the radar there was no VCR I
couldn't see something in backtrack it
you couldn't see something and be like
let me go back into now I'm on a journey
you're like I haven't got ready to jerk
off to this exact moment like woman in
red yeah woman in red with a check the
hot chick she was the one from with
science oh the one yeah Kelly LeBrock
was awesome Kelly LeBrock was pure heat
yeah science was a movie that could ah
weird science she's beautiful the one
she did when she married poor Stephen
yeah yeah Steven Seagal ruined the
[ __ ] career he was [ __ ] beautiful
but you uh
I'm the generation of like the VHS a--'s
of those so you would get like the VHS
of weird science and then jerk off to
the Kelly LeBrock coming out other than
a girl yeah yeah and then you just like
all right
and then eventually common than chats on
the screen and you like what me one time
what's his name goes to ring her
doorbell she gets out of bed and she's
naked
yeah and for a split second you see a
[ __ ]
I still remember 1986 fries in that game
so coked-up yeah and just like trying to
get a hot on and just pleasing some
aprox [ __ ] like you didn't see the
clinton nothing yeah a little black bush
ahead of her getting out of the window
getting out of bed and looking out the
window and then they don't show it again
i think the first one for me was maybe
titanic with the boob that wasn't for
city i think so i don't know
that's the first one I can remember be
like oh my god the first chair I saw
wasn't I went to see The Godfather uncle
takes his shirt off
yeah I'm honeymoon like when I had
almost exploded like I was ten like all
right now I know why my mom hides those
bras they know what a brow is for yeah
did you realize the seal was something
great and she didn't have good Apollonia
yeah did not Hopalong he was hot though
she was beautiful she had like she
already had a kid titties yeah I'm
saying she already had like two Mexican
ka orders she's on the come back to her
titties on the comeback thought so like
that was that was I just wanted to talk
about HBO like for yeah Schwartz saying
and my mother kept it just for the rest
kept it and you know you just started
watching stuff you got Carlin a bunch of
Harlan Harlan like he's like 10 at HBO
yeah you get something crazy and that's
that yeah and then they had lost you
know I lost calm my mom died and then H
then we got HBO get me and my buddy in
high school chipped in and got HBO yeah
that's for 200 bucks you get somebody to
connect a pole and he'd give you
everything so they do admit live next
door to me yeah and he was selling boxes
250 lifetime subscription
I was just rated ax born from China
[ __ ] porn rapes that happened on the
street that people caught with anything
else they had everything on that like
you know with margin
yeah weird [ __ ] 200 bucks one-time
payment yeah
then after about six months they put a
trap on your box then you would call him
they take the trap off and I still
remember the best month ever it's weird
I saw Mike binder last night at the
store and man he's awesome Mike binders
the man in Mike mind is the man and he
had a movie called Hollywood nights in
1981 yeah and it was that this is HDL
only had yeah so weird how I put on TV
now on HBO HBO 9 yeah you know yeah you
Latino it's be a regular comedy HBO our
Ukraine no 1 2 3
HBO Trump and well yeah Eastern West
only audio when I was growing up on
[ __ ] HBO they had eight movies I'm
hopefully put mine on the original yeah
and they had eight movies that's it and
every night for a month
they played those same movies only a
different order so me and my buddy had a
bath we would come home at 12:00 walk
the path mark shoplift ice cream like we
got what he hand out as I got $4.00 what
would the essential little shop will
lift the rest
yeah so we would like shoplift like
salami and [ __ ] like that but we buy ice
cream and eggs and we go home and make
like protein shakes and salami
sandwiches on white bread and we'd watch
the Raging Bull Hollywood nights and
thief with James Caan oh God every night
I just turn it on and you get guaranteed
one of what one of those movies is gonna
be on he never got behind it was gonna
be thief and oh come on and that was
gonna be Hollywood nights yeah it was
like three in order so you if you get
theif you're like I got a Raging Bull
next and I feel that dark for a while
yeah but they started showing a lot of
[ __ ] they had a show we talked about
red Shoe Diaries
they had retro Diaries had the
hitch-hiker the hitchhike I don't
remember the hitchhiker HIV was just
lonely dude that walked on the road my
son cool no he was just a dirty white
dude that walked around and hot white
women would [ __ ] him all over and there
was like titties Bush but they wouldn't
show penetration yeah but good it's a
lot of him holding her man
we're back right and my quad-core yeah
he would [ __ ] her in a car yeah
or in a tent outside or they would do
something along the road and then she
would leave him and then he would walk
in the following episode someone else
come up you just dick it from town to
town that would come on like at 12:30
when on Fridays and then they had Tales
from the Crypt
loved it loved that tells him something
of some little [ __ ] was talking all
that [ __ ] right yeah I love that I was
like I was kind of the age where I hit
puberty right as HBO went titty heavy
like with like dream on which was like a
comedy show but they would always show
titties you just knew at one point in
the episode you're like I'm gonna see
titties and I was at that age kind of
like you were at were you you're like
timing it out really like all right
dream dream ons on let's get ready and
then the 1080 like oh but then we had
tapes of like cinemax movies cuz Cinemax
came along and was like we know what you
guys want just a little bit of story and
a lot of soft glow max just disgusting
yeah well they just came along like
here's this here's a softcore porn which
was the best yeah they started like
10:30 yeah and you were just like cuz
you knew that because my friend Mitch
had the box had the black box and
unscrambled everything so you'd get the
spice channel but it was at my friend's
house and that you don't wanna suck
watching porn like seven other
twelve-year-old dudes in a room like
alright I got to get at it everyone
would leave I recorded just get
eventually back I get the [ __ ] here
still wanted to go home and jerk off
because you're like watching porn and
now kids just it's just on their phones
they're just like oh just look at porn
you had to like find it like a truffle
pig you know like dig for it and I'm
wailed and all you yeah but you came up
nice to remember when you had to send
the money order for 1995 for for pornos
or the projector and a projector and and
would you have to intercept it you'd
have to take it to somebody's house
those parents worked all day so the box
would land there and so you'd have to
sit down watch the mailman come and once
you put them that drawer got out
and pornos were not produced it's a
camera with some broken-down woman who
they dragged into a room it was just
horrible porno from the 70s was really
the me - yeah that's from one who said
what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah you know women getting dragged by
the hair into a room Yellen and three
Puerto Ricans [ __ ] yeah it was just
it was porn all that scared jack yeah
you are like not gonna for shook you I
remember being in a room and when the
kitchen when I did a stress factor yeah
he showed up and he sat in the front row
and I go ladies and gentlemen if you've
got a question about any of my stories
now is the time to ask them yeah and I
just started unloading on him and I saw
as a child
she's shallow and I even good in Miami
this week because there was a kid who
lived across the street from the ground
wasn't that what I said I but I still
him i order in that porn getting the box
and six of us chipped in libelous
chipped in like four hours apiece and we
fought dude that was someone's right and
so what it was an investment we're
waiting you know every day that you get
back yeah Lee did you go by there I was
there all day the mailman didn't come
well it's because it would say six to
eight weeks so with someone market in a
calendar you to like put it in yeah I
think we meld on the 13th there's like a
countdown so as we had a countdown going
so once the six weeks came we were ready
to blow we've hit the corn yet did you
just eventually start jerking off to the
idea of the package getting there just
getting the god I thought the party was
in my attic huh we put [ __ ] a sheet
up on the wall alright sandwiches we
[ __ ] covered the window and aluminum
for like a crack yeah we put that porn
on and we were traumatized like
traumatized to the point that I'm not a
hooker guy yeah or a strip club guy or
anything from what I saw so if we had a
reaction I'm telling you the truth is he
had a joke yeah I think back you look at
my personality and wild man yes I love
[ __ ] and I love everything but you
leave eight years well we went to a
strip club
he has never
yeah just cause of that video just that
video just gave me like I don't even
watch Poland people send me [ __ ] yeah
you know if somebody says to me this
girl was at the store yeah I'll look up
her name if I meet a porn chick yeah and
she tells me her name I'll look her up
or something but besides that I don't
look up or anything about it I know this
pornhub and youporn and it was it was a
cuz of that like after that video even
as a kid did you were you just like how
I was very Catholic yeah you know I was
raised by a single mom there was she
spoke sexual but I didn't like it yeah
and then seeing that [ __ ] me how old
were you even you suck I probably I
gotta say 13 okay and we had an 11 year
old in the room but he just started
crying yeah like he just started he just
broke down I think that shows you were
real like hey he's got six kids so I
don't know I don't know if it's because
of that Poland or whatever snapped him
in the line snapped you guys scared
straight with the first I mean your
first poor thing here's the thing even
when it's not a terrible situation even
when it's a good like I saw probably
like a late 80s Early 90s porn for my
firstborn it was still the first
hardcore porn you see I was maybe around
the same age 13 14 years old and you're
like oh oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] because
it's so graphic and more hardcore but
than like to make it worse like you see
that could snap you shut somebody
approached me this week a publicist and
they wrote me this long note about a
client they have he wants to come on the
podcast and talk about you know porn
addiction in the country and I looked at
him on my him and how it ties him with
human trafficking and you know I would
have had him if he would have cut it
short at the porn addiction yeah because
I love to learn about that stuff but I
don't want to hear about human
trafficking on the show that takes the
show somewhere else yeah you know I like
this show because from time to time even
if we get serious we do crack a few
jokes in between there's no you know I
talking to a guy I'm gonna trap you and
try to crack a joke talk about human
trafficking
every day we drive here in North
Hollywood you see all these massage
parlors and I can't even think like I go
to one massage parlor bag that I take my
wife there yeah I took believe that call
Ching moon the Sun like that and they do
foot rubs it's all guys it's legit it's
not one chick it's legit but all those
are the ones on Lankershim they're all
tug and hugs yeah and if you ever go in
there like one Christmas my back hurt
and everyone I went into like I walked
and I was like you know what let me make
an appointment because I could tell ya
just to look that and the woman looked
broken you could tell they're human
trafficked so you could tell by walking
in the door if you they would look at
you and just be like you [ __ ] here we go
I gotta [ __ ] this guy for freedom like
oh my god I'll jump off the [ __ ]
bridge do you run now so you have that
freedom is about the [ __ ] this guy
Fenner is funny me as I watch this
documentary and it's the biggest
concentration of learning he's really
and I've had friends go to Houston to
say oh my god we went to a massage
parlor
she looked like Lucy Liu she wanted 300
and she let you [ __ ] her in the ass
condom you know just crazy she oh yeah
there's some comics we were [ __ ]
savages yeah you find out some guys and
you're like man you should have been in
the 15th century oh yeah there's some
comments there just that's that's
innocent there's some comics we I was
always drawn to the drug part of it the
second was sex
you know yeah the crazy hose alcohol
first the book day you bump into on the
road for some guys I know three comics
who blew their lives over their sex
addiction well I would never say nothing
- I've never said it to them but I know
that their sex addiction yeah costume
that comedy career the same way a drunk
problem with alcohol or drug problem or
cuz I think about that cuz I stopped
drinking six years ago and and you think
like I have a friend who over eats you
know it means like 500 pounds and I
think about that I'm like man I hope
that what a hard thing to stop because
the thing that's you got to stop the
thing that you have to do I don't have
to ever drink alcohol like sex if you're
a sex addict you want to have sex again
with your wife so it's weird
you know it would be like if I had to
drink a beer every day in the back don't
be an hour
holic that's a weird addiction to think
and I feel like I'm lucky that I don't
have it I was gonna say oh yeah I'm sure
I don't want to I'm sure it's hard this
parts to it but sex addiction seems like
the ELA Beth like it doesn't seem like
it's that bad I think it could [ __ ]
destroy your life destroy how you know
I'll because I have a dear friend that I
got to meet out here yeah and after four
years I asked yeah she became friends
with my wife there's no other Denali
what she moved back to New York yeah and
she just told me this sex addict thing
and weed smoke joints and yeah one day I
just said break it down for me and it
was just yeah and it was something with
a father the okay you know but I you
know I don't think I don't think you
know what's born a sex addict I don't
think anyone just comes out like no and
you know what I mean like an unscathed
childhood and there's like I'm a I don't
I feel like it always is
addictions always come from like a
[ __ ] rough landing as a child
absolutely I think I think as a kid it's
like a response to a [ __ ] fall and I
think it runs in something I think like
for me listen I've been addicted to
something since I can remember
yeah you know let's start with my
pacifier addiction sucking your thumb I
gave up pacifiers when I was six okay
and I still remember how I used them I
used them like people smoke cigarettes
will you'd stress out so I play with you
yeah and then let's I lost a game my god
be right back and I'd go on a corne and
suck three times then come back and keep
playing Monopoly just go hacker
pacifiers I had them everywhere all over
the [ __ ] apartment 80 to 90 of them
and my mother had these Japanese dolls
nice to play ball in the house and she
was listen when they gonna break one of
those balls first I'm gonna break your
head yeah who you gonna pay me the 300
all those balls I get playing with this
Baldy number two yeah you know they're a
little harder yeah and I broke the
[ __ ] down and she goes either have to
pay me to 300 or you give up your
dictionnaire pacifiers I knew I wasn't
giving that [ __ ] 300 I'll show you
gotta kill me to get the change I had
saved up from the ball I had exactly
like 310 blowing that [ __ ] doll yeah
and I still remember her and I walking
around the house and me going and and
she had a garbage bag and me throwing
you know I had him hiding in the pillows
I had one like crazy did you have like
Bowl did you have like a like a period
of withdrawal like did she have to leave
you in a room when you're no son I don't
remember like I looked at my daughter
when my daughter had it yeah binky thing
it was over with her with three and that
was enough and I still remember her
asking for it a couple times yeah and
then me coming back from the world and
my wife going don't even bring it up
yeah that was I just moved on but I
guarantee that that addiction turned
into that I became a Karate Kid
okay and I was addicted with that yeah
like that's all them boots we can't but
it drove me over and then from that I
probably got hooked on [ __ ] ice cream
yeah I don't know I hate pizza every day
like yeah hey comes everything I do I'm
a creature of habit
yeah you know it's taken last night
somebody wants to kill me all they gotta
do is go to store the truth Fandango I
make this kid alright every Thursday
night he's gonna be right on my door
every Tuesday yeah you know rain snow
shine
I feel bad Christmas Eve is on Tuesday
and I'm like what do I do
well I gotta go to the store yeah you
know think about that when you have like
habits like that or like kind of like
OCD compulsions like that when it's
something like a holiday and you're like
no but I do just think on this day and
there's like you got a turkey to family
when you do listen for you to get to HBO
yeah you had to have some type of CD
copy nothing to sit down and mate you
write this [ __ ] you have to have OCD to
do it we do over and over and over and
what's weird and repetitive and the same
thought I feel I feel weird when I come
off the road because you go you get so
used to going Thursday this Saturday
back on Sunday you know New York Monday
Tuesday Wednesday back on the road on
Thursday back home Sunday you start
doing that in the past month I stopped
after I film the special I was like
alright I'm just gonna stay in the city
just bought and I started to feel like
look it's itchy itchies the best word
where I was kind of like what the [ __ ]
anyway I was getting bothered easy and
he's like oh yeah we're creatures of
habit you have to go back to doing that
and that's why I like stand up cuz I can
go do the same that go to the cellar
Tuesday night after the bar you know
what I mean like I need two more weeks a
month yeah on the road that's what I do
I need it yeah not financially I just
need to do it I need to do it yeah I
need it for myself I've trained my
family on it already that's the best my
wife loves it yeah you know yeah my
daughter loves it yeah you know the
weeks I go on the road her and I spend
that life stripped I'm sure you know
it's something you know I was thinking
about last night that I'm making it
easier for my daughter understand
hopefully she marries a guy that travels
and it's gonna be like fine yeah you
know because I was the blueprint of her
growing up it she's comfortable with it
I travel six day and I tell I look at
her face it's five [ __ ] days yeah
yeah but I miss you my [ __ ] days and
we keep the lights on
yeah okay yeah I mean I need the road
also yeah I could tell I could tell when
I'm home for a while and you get to the
road is uh what's weird as you start
becoming more of yourself on the road
than at home you know you can either
like a part of you that's like that's
truly you by yourself and you're just
Ennis like I'm nots nice to travel with
features have you know friend with you
sometimes and that makes it easier but
then when you're just like in Buffalo at
helium for five shows and you're like
yeah this is who I am when I'm in Austin
at cap city you know I'm still that guy
during the Saturday after press you
become like that that's just who you are
as a person so then when you don't go on
the road you're kind of like I kind of
miss doing stuff like that it's crazy
how you evolve on the road also because
28 years let's say safely correctly I've
been going on the road like an animal
for 20 conservatively
can I ask you as someone that can't just
start on the road and only gone on the
road with the internet what was that
like before when you're on the road and
there's no
[ __ ] internet or you didn't have
movie channel this is what I'm gonna
tell ya it's so weird white okay right
now Lee's been doing it two years about
three years he's gonna start getting
calls to do one-nighters and whatnot
yeah and at first the road is you you
drop your bags you want to Cleveland you
go to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
go here you go there you you have an
idea you know your feature act so this
you're not gonna go to the best
restaurant in town sure but you're gonna
find affordable and you go out and you
do things and you connect with the
people now every time you go to that
club as a feature act what you're gonna
go to six times yeah you know you're
gonna go there six times before you come
if you're lucky you're getting that work
like that twice - yeah yeah that's twice
a year three years you're gonna go there
as a feature clubs you can see like
three and if they're in rice and then
that they really like you to go stay
next week yeah you know so assuming that
you become friends at the bartend and
that hotel you they fly in Tuesday and
there's a room or now for me that pays
200 and now you start to meet people but
then the road then you get married you
know for you you were drinking yeah she
is
yeah and one day you said you got a stop
because this isn't working on the road
oh man I was well Road is a license to
go yeah when you then and that's why I
tell people the road for me when I
[ __ ] got in that car
June 25th 1995 in Boulder and I headed
out to Ogden Utah that's an open for
tribal you know do it rebel yeah I my
mentality changed you become a savage
yeah
you become Tom Bergen major leagues yeah
I'm up in the big Taylor yeah to make
the mess off of him yeah a chicken in
the room now you can lease a from the
Yankee yeah yeah that's what you become
on the road yeah you all you do is party
write and perform yeah party write and
perform and somewhere on the way the
Tuscaloosa you stop and do laundry and
you bump into a fat black chick who
[ __ ] I'll cook for you and then go
back you know and that's part of the
adventure
sure and then you get then you stop
doing drugs and drink
yeah now the road becomes something
different to you now you're starting to
get special yeah you're dedicating
writing you know you want to get healthy
so now the road becomes a gym also yeah
now you actually look at gyms go to
restaurants go to a different route you
want to get like actual restaurants like
the local Flair yeah you don't want to
go to Morton's into New York you want to
go to the local Flair
let's go up to our Arthur Avenue in the
Bronx that's spaghetti and [ __ ] Meat
Boy
yeah and then for me now the road is uh
it is an escape you know when I'm home I
have a child that's your wife Podcast
you know it's constant when I'm on the
road it's over yeah
it's about my Netflix yeah my notebook
and what I could walk to to eat that's
why you see when you tell me the best I
don't like that right now I walk to
where I mean the best restaurant is
choo-choos yeah I looked it and I look
at Twitter I look at uber if it's more
than a 10 spot I don't need to go there
you know I live in LA I don't want to be
another car and I want to walk breathe
get some vitamin D yeah cuz I'm gonna be
in my hotel room see I look it I always
look for the restaurants that are in
between the club in the hotel if you
find something and you're like alright
that's on the way so I can get it or
take it back for some reason there was a
couple months where I just wanted to get
food and go back to my hotel room like
you want to go back to your baby early
like I like food in my room you don't
know so I use like when I go so you go
out to eat you know to my AK yeah you go
to my AK oh yeah they got great food and
[ __ ] die yeah yeah got a Chinese
restaurant that delivers okay and they
got a [ __ ] Italian restaurant it
delivers yeah but we we did this show
Thursday night Friday me and Matt full
Tron
we just got [ __ ] a bag of Italian
food 50 bucks
spaghetti and clam sauce here Shanna
[ __ ] pizza the folder and that was
all in for the day we just each took
three slices I took three slices and
then Saturday it was Chinese you know
but we eat
downstairs and the breakfast area yeah
so we'll sit there watching like when I
was on TV so you go to the lobby and eat
[ __ ] yeah well I bring food back yeah a
lobby and eat you know what that's a
good point because I always known as I
get food in my room the the messiest
food is when you bring it back and then
you get like you'll get like a corner of
a to-go thing that'll open up and that's
on the desk every note every bedspread
is white yeah [ __ ] room once in San
Diego and I brought a pot cookie with me
and it was a little baggie yeah I put
the pot cookie in the shelf and the next
morning I woke up and this was a [ __ ]
Hilton this is like a Hilton yeah this
is like a whole guess like they're white
people yeah you know that a mouse ate
the tail end of the cookie yeah the
baggie he ate through the baggie so it
was like a fan cookie guys didn't eat
much I'm not gonna why do you say he
thought he ate like maybe this much of
the cookie but can you imagine a mouse
oh my god he's that's why he had a stop
he's eaten he's thinking he's getting up
he's like a bakery here and also his
diabetes hit him but yeah [ __ ]
one under the sink and died that
[ __ ]
he got through he was fighting through
that bag knowing what was on the other
side he's like a whole cook he's
probably thinking of the cookie who's
gonna give to his family how he was
generations that he was eating at these
like this what the [ __ ] just puttin him
sideways [ __ ] that little mouse up
[ __ ] that's where you gotta do
instead of trash you see Joey Diaz we'd
cookies at the post cut one of his
cousin's on the train you know those
trains on the a train were you waiting
for the mouse yeah the Train something
go by let's stop a smoker yeah that
Mouse got into jazz and he just started
walking over [ __ ] train tracks and
you start to see him in New York City
yeah you're like okay I'm not [ __ ]
saying things yeah they the tracks in
New York you just it's actually the way
I feel like if you live near a river you
would watch a river run he's just watch
like rats run down the subway tracks and
it's like if you don't get skis that you
like their whatever they're down there
so the special came out last Saturday
yeah yeah so now totally streaming
streaming on all the platforms how you
feeling about it
good man but it's like that new like
alright let's get back to work it's a
horrible free all right yeah that's
horrible it's it's it's two things it's
like exciting because you feel like you
have a whole field in front of you like
just go run around but then you're kind
of like man I had some structured bits I
had some bits that I really worked the
[ __ ] out long did you taste between you
shut this specially prepared I think we
did the stand-ups on Netflix in March of
2017 and so from March 2017 to October
of 2019 so about two and a half years
you had plenty of yeah and I went to
Edinburgh Scotland and worked on it yeah
our okay good and just work that
sumbitch worked you know wanted to get
it as tight as I could and then film it
and then it was just Wade you're filming
Bowery Ballroom no [ __ ] yeah I would
feel great great is it was a it's a
great rock venue but it's also just a
good venue got about 400 people in there
HBO shot a couple specials or just you
they shot uh they did like 7:00 in 2019
I want to say there's about seven or
eight specials so I'm the last one of
the year but in a yellow man it's great
it's that's HBO I got him do the 1983
special presentation intro or you see
the dad turning the TV and then they go
up over the town and you know it comes
out of the stars the banning in it I was
like man if I could just get that on
this special and though I can't we'll do
it
that's like [ __ ] it that's great alright
roll everything Andy hey just so you
just ask for [ __ ] look you know we're
your parents now you said you grew up in
Colorado yeah open Aurora my mom is
still out there she's still living in
Aurora and then my dad died when I was
14 Sosa's oh thanks yeah it's just uh
just been there and my grandmother still
lives out in San Francisco so I spend
those are the two places I go I hate to
ask you this World War you we talked
about before the podcast I have a deep
deep love for Colorado
yeah and I'm gonna tell you what
happened
the people listening in Denver I just
went to Denver and I did two shows at
the Paramount and I went back to the
room I cried a little bit that night
yeah because I've been to every state in
the [ __ ] Union you know Alaska Hawaii
pretty much I haven't done comedy in all
of them but Colorado is a special place
where it was when I first stepped foot
in Colorado in 1983 it was a magical
kingdom especially where I came from in
New York City and New Jersey yeah I'm
from right over the tunnel yes he's all
oh that's warm from yeah and then New
York City and listen not to take
anything away from New York City when
New York City sneezes everybody catches
a cold New York runs this [ __ ] but when
I went to Colorado like I just it was
something magical yeah like what I was
expecting and what I saw with two
different things did you think it was
just gonna be like a podunk tiny cow
town I still remembered being a 3-man
that's I Colorado Denver's not big and
eating I still remember being a child
and them always going tonight on ABC you
know whatever
six o'clock central 7:00 o'clock Pacific
eight o'clock mountain time yeah and
mountain time always [ __ ] amiss yeah
so when somebody came up to me and they
go listen you're not doing too well here
I got a spot in Basalt
it's 45 minutes from Aspen you know we
got a house there you're more than
welcome to come on get your head
together Wow but so I went you know in
those days you did not go online yeah
went to the library I was a bookie on
118th Street okay and I went to some New
York library and I got an encyclopedia
and looked up Colorado and I read all
about it and I was like I guess I'll go
out there right I pictured the Little
House on the Prairie in here I remember
waking up on i-70 and seeing all this
Commerce and all this [ __ ] yeah but we
weren't had that we were headed
basalt yes yeah go through Colorado you
go through them we go through the
foothills and all sudden you start to
see this Georgetown you've owned by
Georgetown on i-70 to see it you know
what went it went you know except for
the mountains it looked like [ __ ]
Newark you know downtown then whatever
the [ __ ] you know downtown was a
hellhole when I moved to come here so we
didn't stop and then what we drove
through Dettol and I was like not that
bueno but once we got on Denver and you
start feeling those mountains yeah and I
gotta be honest with you there's a lot
of people you think I'm crazy
you don't feel it cuz you grew up there
I didn't grow up there but their first
time I was surrounded by mountains
something happens to you you know
something happens to you they're
mountains you really have an effect on
you well I lived in Seattle
I would go to Bremerton and that's the
deepest point in the United States
that's why they have launched submarines
I don't comment in okay and when you're
there when you live close to the ocean
and you live in a city like New York
then you move to Colorado there's some
type of energy in those mountains and I
felt I felt at peace for the first time
I didn't have to do coke for the first
time I slept I also relaxed you I
learned how to go fishing yeah you know
yeah I mean that's not only skiing and
Mammoth you know growing up there I
think you don't realize you do not
realize because it's a gene you're from
but you from like um you're from like a
smaller town you know Denver is a small
town and you're watching you there's I
was growing up with cable so you're
watching shows based in New York and
[ __ ] and in Denver was a small town and
then you'd go to the mountains to do
things with your parents but that was
kind of like you were going on because
they wanted to do something and for you
you're like this sucks I'd rather be at
home with my friends running around
doing that stuff so I never really
appreciated the mountains until I left
Colorado and came back and then I was
like oh holy [ __ ]
but also in a weird way that's also why
I think I appreciate New York so much is
because I grew up in a place like Denver
where there is a it's a lower
pace it's a slower pace kind of everyone
there is that there's room out there
then I moved to New York and I just
liked that everything was there and you
could get to work and it was like if you
wanted to work you could go so I think
you know having that opposite either
growing up in a different place like New
York and Denver and then having it as an
adult you can appreciate both because I
don't think there's a better place that
could have grown up then Denver called
in Aurora suburbs of a nice you know how
can be beautiful it's sunny beYOU so
sunny all those white people yeah you
gotta remember I moved to [ __ ] basalt
yeah and the first thing we did for
dinner the first night was go to a place
where they gave you a fishing pole I'm a
New York City I handled guns
I threw rocks at people you got a
descaler face people give you a fishing
pole for ten bucks you throw it in the
Roaring Fork you catch a trout they take
it they skinned it they cook it and then
they give you a potato salad two pieces
of bread Nabire that was my first
experience I was like what the [ __ ] that
is how cool is this [ __ ] and everybody's
talking to people and I still talk Toby
prepare somebody Brooke put it up on
Twitter I still remember hitchhiking
yeah like the big thing in Basalt was
they had a hitching post so you can
hitchhike and people would actually pull
up and go I'm not going up that far
today I'm so sorry
good morning though and I go [ __ ] yeah
that's not from New York you don't fly
tell me good morning I still remember
going home the first day I applied for
jobs and I still my buddies like so
how'd it go today I'm like I'm not out
of here they're [ __ ] [ __ ] they
tell you good morning how are you they
ask you how you do have they talked to
you we were raised to look straight you
don't look down
you don't make eye contact oh I swear to
God I still am a high king and a lady
pulling up and going good morning
I would give you a ride but I can't come
only going ahead old Snowmass and me
gone honey stop what the [ __ ] is will
get below in your mind that some low in
my mind
was that nice it almost feels did it
feel like intrusive like someone
realized like something I never it took
me a month to get you through these and
then I was all in but what happened when
you went back east after getting used to
the Colorado conversation it took me
about eight months I stayed and I really
enjoy that I learned how to ski by
myself
I'm Christmas Day 83 I was all in but I
brought luggage with me I brought my
Thievery luggage with me and Snowmass
Village is the size of [ __ ] three
blocks yeah and I started robbing
jewelry stores and burglarizing the mall
Christmas Eve so I had backed myself out
of position so I'm left then I came back
a year and a half later moved back up
there like nothing had happened
again I left him disgrace ended up
getting arrested and bold now when I
moved to Aspen I went to Boulder and I
was in Boulder five minutes before I
told I looked at my buddies and I go get
the [ __ ] car why would you bring me
to this filthy hippie stinky
sandal-wearing [ __ ] place you're just
up on the hill watching all those houses
go around and go to the hill yet I was
down on Pearl Street Mall yeah and
they'll get me the [ __ ] out of here
people playing the guitar all in super
[ __ ] Colorado I'm not going back to
Boulder yeah don't be animal
I'm never gonna bear all white everybody
had sandals on and that went to New York
got a beat in New York ended up homeless
the whole thing her plane right back to
Colorado I said I'm moving to Colorado
Springs and I bumped into a black guy on
the flight neither the man you don't
want to move to no Colorado's when is
that's our Midtown yep you're Air Force
how do you want 21 you want some [ __ ]
you gotta move to Boulder yeah so I
landed got a hotel room took a bus to
Boulder the next day and I moved to 10
12 14 Street right on the [ __ ] Hill
around the corner from [ __ ] down
I'm Club 1816 and over yeah we're kanay
vez McGee points the guy in the eye and
knocked his eyeball out and should
tremendous this was that's [ __ ] all of
them a Bo's pizza I could throw a rock
at the University of Colorado yeah I'm
1012 14th Street you did I know exactly
where that is cuz my all my friends
older brothers and sisters went to
Boulder so when I was in high school
you'd go up and go to those house
parties you know and you just like
Halloween the Halloween house parties if
you're a high school kid in Aurora and
you wonder your friends older brothers
went to Colorado you like oh let's go up
there and drink you just go into a keg
and pay five bucks but you're like 17 it
was [ __ ] great I'm going away to a
ski resort for New Year's with my
daughter the main reason is to see how
she adapts to skiing and how she likes
the cold weather yeah if she likes the
cold weather
I predict that within three years I'll
be living in the Grand Junction area
Grand Junction I'm moving to that crane
church why Grand Junction though why not
I told Sally Ride I got all that it
hasn't been polluted yet with the
marijuana yeah and there's still houses
for $300,000 that's why not that's why I
know Breckenridge Grand Junction Airport
flies directly to JFK of LAX seasonal so
you could still get out of there great
if anyone ever told me they removed a
Grand Junction that Grand Junction in
that area yeah Grand Junction I have a
dear friend and we would have some okay
I have a dear friend
I have friends he was just hit micro
buck okay yeah and we spoke and he goes
you start of plans and I don't gonna
surprise you his family owns a
supermarket chain out there not King
Soopers was about to say knocking our
guy super not King super duper yeah how
far is Denver from it oh that's like a
fog over a six-hour drive Wow you gotta
go through the Rockies that's on the
other side that's the west side of the
Rockies Wow God when I show my point
being that to this day I'm very ashamed
of my behavior in Colorado if I woulda
done that behavior in New York San
Francisco LA it was accepted the
but Colorado that meat still remains a
very special place yeah I don't like the
marijuana say in Colorado
realize I think it brought to me Oh
Colorado been smokin big dopes is a
tease all right
Colorado gotta prove to nobody so I was
in Colorado 83 and I was getting weed no
[ __ ] hair on your walls at high
altitude get the [ __ ] no I when I went
to college I went to college at Tucson I
would receive Arizona and before I left
yeah I went up to Boulder and I got an
ounce I got a I got a and it was four
buds for long buds and it was I waited
28 grams and I took it with me to Tucson
thinking everyone had the equivalent of
Boulder wheat because when I was in high
school Boulder weed was that's what you
wanted to get it that was what the first
time I saw weed with orange hairs the
first time the sticky [ __ ] of it was
Boulder and ever I brought that with me
and people in Tucson were like where's a
[ __ ] did you get this we don't
understand yeah I'm not even talking
about Bowl I'm talking about Colorado as
a whole yeah well I lived in Aspen I
still got a Woody Creek tap yeah all
right
great hunter s Thompson's watering hole
scene Hunter s Thompson and I could a
lie to you guys to tell you I didn't
know what the [ __ ] he was a Bill Murray
okay
they were just about to shoot where the
buffalo roam all right left I found that
that he was then I want in there another
time and he was in there with Don
Johnson because Woody Creek time and
made the best [ __ ] nachos they used
real chorizo yeah nobody uses chorizo on
their nachos that's that's that's
mind-boggling 1983 oh bring a chorizo
and Joe Colorado to Colorado so [ __ ]
I would go down there and I would get
weed the first time the person showed me
the weed I don't know if it was the
lighting in the room it looked like coke
from how the crystals yeah or on the bud
so for people who don't know now you
know they've been smoking
deep reefer in Colorado those
[ __ ] I had some people will
grow
where they made the shiny yeah that's
shiny my mom worked at that hotel I'm
not [ __ ] twins yeah yeah how good the
buffet is there on Sunday I don't know
I've never offended my mom worked there
up and cost him in the hotel it's not
it's the it's not the [ __ ] it simcha
it's the Broadmoor something like the
Stanley is what it's called rights the
Stanley in the book but I think it's the
Broadmoor Hotel in in real life in real
life they have a buffet the Stanley or
the yeah I think it's still the Stanley
they have a buffet for Sunday's yeah
it's the best buffet my mom worked that
that that hotel is really haunted yes
very hard to tell my my mom worked there
in the summer yes and she worked up a
phase which was like a big that's a big
deal at the hotel the weekend the famous
town one that's him that's this part
that's this part Colorado I don't know
if it's this is still true but as of ten
years ago Estes Park was number one
visited tourist location in the United
States I thought it was the Grand Canyon
yeah really bad squirrels that come up
to you you could feed him you let blue
bad squirrels think that's cool but
that's that's great but that hotel my
mom worked the breakfast shift and she
said like dude coming into the tables
would be like you know chairs on the
tables and stuff like everything moved
around and they have to reset it but
then he's became like used to it cuz
that hotel was the haunted there was
like I yeah
ghosts are [ __ ] with us again you're
not cool then there's shining and then
they made the shiny so I think my mom
was in college when they made the
shining or was that late 70s when did
the shining come out let's find out to
say come out I want to see that new on
dr. sleep 80 okay yes she's waiting on
but it was yes and I was just moving up
there okay so you look up there hey
moved up the snow mass on the heels of
Ted Bundy [ __ ] dude oh you always forget
about Colorado stopover yeah you forget
to funny to the car Aspen Weiss and he
killed the chick at the Wildwood Inn and
Snowmass and I used to hang out at the
stone bridge which is right up the block
so they would go that's the first place
they take guns okay
where that Bundy killed the people would
take it you want secret everybody bash
that lady's head in Maine oh yeah oh
yeah you figured about the Colorado
stopover of Ted Bundy you think mostly
Washington in Florida you know Colorado
was a very unique place like I said it
means the world to me because I became a
man there yeah that married divorced I
failed there as a man I went to prison
there learn how to shoot yeah I would
have to kill people there me that had a
trainer there that was that's all he did
blow up people why is battery acid Jesus
you know because they hate they they
used to hide a lot of Vietnam vets in
Colorado to protect Nora I didn't know
that's [ __ ] crazy because Nora is in
Colorado it's in the mountain so they
would have they would you know I just
heard this hum all true this that they
would actually send a lot of pictures I
knew a guy in Snowmass Village that once
a year he wore his costume and the
helicopter would come and get him and
then he'd leave and they come back and
he'd be a skier but besides that he had
19 racks of [ __ ] medals and that's
not John J Rambo and people had stories
about him and then I became friends with
him because I worked at a video store
yeah and one day I asked him I said you
really agree and beret and he goes yeah
are you guys the best he goes well a
green beret a seal or [ __ ] this no
this was sitting an arranger was sitting
around making a bowl of stew and Ranger
was telling his stories and the seal was
telling his story and this guy was his
story the whole time the marine was
stirring the pot with his dick that's
the story told me that's how tough I am
all right come get him and then there
was a there was a guy at head of the
name John link he had added above the
law okay
commando yeah and this what's the Steven
Seagal movie hard to kill
yeah no no no one would either yes yes
on one hand right you know he's in a
coma for yeah
to kill some two weeks ladies flying
through the air talking [ __ ] I yeah he
woke up and saw himself yeah I love that
acupuncture himself out of a coma and
then you know this is one 887 they wrote
some cocaine additive you're making
those movies is he yeah go direct to in
Hong Kong it's and beaten all those
protesters that's the next to go hard to
protest how to protest here what date
you got coming up I'm gonna be in San
Francisco I'm gonna be in Boston all
dates at Dan Soder calm I'm hitting the
road again January not hard okay get
that new you know put that new hour
together I hear you man thanks so much
for having me on it it's like Christ
should call me two nights ago
he's starting Thursdays at the haha
workout Thursdays he goes on how to
start from scratch again yeah and it's
horrible it's terrible cuz you're like
it's a month do I know how to write a
[ __ ] month of suicidal thoughts
because you're like what the [ __ ] am I
gonna say all I keep thinking about is
like what does that even mean okay and
you don't book yourself for an hour
because you do because you might as well
embarrass yourself but you gotta like
Albany like you know they just got two
feet of snow and they don't give a [ __ ]
if you go up to hit yourself with a
hammer or that saying that I'm gonna
[ __ ] up you bomb up and all but it is a
weekend yeah that's why I gotta wait
till January to be like alright I got a
semblance of something something
something yeah yeah figure something out
but uh man thanks so much for having me
on man first time I ever saw you know I
heard of you and but I came through our
life or just a quick stop and I met up
with Ari at the Comedy Store and I was
with Louie Katz and we were waiting for
Ari and we walked him to the back of the
original room and I saw you do this set
and I was like man Joey Diaz [ __ ]
hilarious because that I just that was
it was just for some reason while I was
waiting for Ari
Louie and I walked in sat down wash you
and you're doing a story about teaching
a cat how to do blow and it was one of
the [ __ ] a harder
laughs and I'm never leaving to be like
you Joey Diaz is a [ __ ] beast just
you know and I don't get out to LA a lot
so it's just nice to meet you and I'm
thanks for having me on and I'd love to
do the bonfire do one in your wouldn't
you tape I do Monday through Wednesday 6
to 8 p.m. so Monday Tuesday Wednesday
night yeah 6 days
[ __ ] Jays a hard work he's got that
legion his skank oh [ __ ] sex drugs and
rock and roll he's doing a great new
show at the stand that you definitely
have to do called the worst where you
tell a story and Jay kind of interjects
with thoughts or whatever I've done it
what nice to do that he doesn't once a
month but if he ever doesn't know like
dude I'm telling you man that just me
dream booking you on the worst with big
Jay would be the [ __ ] but dude I Love
You Man thank you very much thank you
very much that Colorado connection it
was no no we gotta get you back on the
history I mean yeah I love that [ __ ] and
I miss Colorado but I love him miss York
I miss and that's that's why I told my
wife I go before we spend a ton of loot
called a vacation in Grand Junction and
flying here whole thing let's see how
she handles Big Bear or and if she likes
the snow and she likes falling down and
all that [ __ ] I'm out of here
I'm the Colorado bomb I ask for
forgiveness row column to you with
warning kids just to give me good karma
yeah because I always felt like that was
the wrong place to do the things I was
doing I am a Rogen moving to Boulder and
calling me and going I'm driving in this
town
and I'm seeing you and you this was
nothing [ __ ] candy store for you yeah
you know I Sterman were gonna Kmart on
Christmas yeah and in Boulder yeah the
place is closed the gate was open there
was no attendant there was ten you know
couple trees like I said don't leave
your payment in the thing and I'm like
no he didn't and I'm broke I look in the
envelope there's 200 I take the cash and
I'll leave the checks and I steal the
Christmas tree I felt so bad about that
I went back and put 200 and this thing
and I didn't tell him for what you know
there was a story that I didn't do
yeah but this is how nice people in
Colorado are and you people listening
I'm a [ __ ] stupid know there's so
nice in Boulder a [ __ ] guy put five
boxes in front of five drive-ins in the
bank of Boulder yeah so they're driving
lanes yeah big bank with drivers he put
a box in a sign that said window closed
put deposits in here you receive
receipts in the mail he did that till
lunchtime til they caught on he came out
all five boxes god knows what he stole
my stir people oh okay I couldn't I was
like a bully then yeah like you know
people leave your keys in the ignition
in the car now you get to move back and
now I get to move back and try to be a
normal [ __ ]
I love that all right they love you
dance in the past listen uh the church
is brought to you by don't forget dance
soda special came out on Saturday night
catch it on HBO he's a funny guy he's a
great guy and I'm happy that he made it
on today I want to thank him I want to
thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for supporting the Church
of what's happening now let me explain
something at holiday season it's coming
you're sitting there what am I gonna hit
this guy what am I gonna get Jimmy well
yeah I got something for you and it
starts at $79 the hello - she portable
bidet you're like Joey why would I need
a birthday why because why would you
need to cut down a thousand [ __ ]
trees to wipe your ass wiping your butt
with dried toilet paper doesn't remove
all this [ __ ] it leaves all the [ __ ]
there speedy toes behind you got poop on
any other part of your body we just wipe
it off with dry paper no water cleans
better than dry paper you [ __ ] Momo
tushies face sprays water directly into
your [ __ ] and removes everything
listen but days are common all over the
world except here
a bidet saves you money on toilet paper
you still use a little toilet paper to
patch it down but the amount doesn't
matter
we also over at tisha they got
tremendous little Turkish towels to dry
your [ __ ] clean till she sprays some
water into your [ __ ] ass
not toilet water I'm talking about till
she connects to the water supply behind
your toilet to spray your dirty parts
your nutsack your [ __ ] that cracked
with fresh water the same water you
brush your teeth with wet wipes are
worse than [ __ ] toilet paper listen
take it from your uncle Joey if you wipe
with paper you're gonna leave [ __ ]
cause anal fixes and you don't want to
have no anal fissures and your [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright so the days of the way
to go they started $79 they come in
different colors they got a 60-day
guarantee but let me tell you some I've
had mine for what maybe four [ __ ]
years I'm true beyond 300 [ __ ] pounds
and it still washes my [ __ ]
tip top my guru so so go the hello - she
knocked out right now press in church
get 10% off your order any time right
now this is the gift to give you show up
with this they're gonna be [ __ ] happy
and it's easy to install you don't need
a plumber you can do it all on your own
go - hello - she calm right now let me
tell you something else the church is
brought to you by Stan's socks they're
the most comfortable socks that you
could possibly wear get them Stan's
socks they're just not comfy they're
gonna turn heads their designs are
beyond anything you've ever seen on a
sock they're works of art whatever
you're into if they got Metallica they
got the Karate Kid they got the whole
Quentin Tarantino collection every
football every baseball every basketball
team they got something for every sports
fanatic in your life this Christmas let
me tell you some of these socks they're
just comfortable you ever just put a
pair of socks on when I fly I put on my
stance why when I go to lift weights I
put on my stance why because they're
comfortable they make your feet feel
like a million bucks you know I'm saying
they're like [ __ ] an SUV for your
feet they're comfortable they they just
tremendous and this again is another
tremendous Christmas present all right
now footage for the church family I got
a great offer you ready go to stance
calm right now and you'll get a free
pair of socks with any purchase purchase
a pair socks they're gonna throw a pair
of socks in alright
dance is the best way to cross everyone
off your holiday shopping list that
stance grab a pen sta and see e-comm
slash sure to get your free pair of
socks because if they're not Stan's
they're not socks they're just pieces of
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
go to Stan's dot-com right now Stan's
STA and see e.com slash Church and get a
free pair of socks when you order
whatever they have to sell you that who
takes care you're like uncle Joey
I want to thank lol douchey and I want
to thank Stan's socks and most
importantly I want to thank you [ __ ]
savages Colusa casino is sold out
there's maybe two tickets left for the
Christmas show up at the ice house in
San Francisco the second show there's
still some tickets left
Palace of Performing Arts and it's after
Christmas so we'll have a good time on a
saturday night I love you guys do not
forget to watch the Dan Soder special on
HBO I want to thank the [ __ ]
I want to thank [ __ ] Stan's soda but
I want to thank you guys for being
[ __ ] family and thank you for all the
compliments on mercy she is a great kids
I'm trying my hardest I love you
[ __ ] - see you Monday morning or
maybe Tuesday I don't know I haven't
made up my mind yet but I'll see you
next week all right
stay black god bless you don't let
nobody [ __ ] with you take this [ __ ] to
me Lee